hey everybody so i want to jump
on right away today instead of you know
a big dramatic build up because we do
have the first biden harris
campaign appearance so let's listen in
right away we do have trump scheduled
for the bottom of the hour and we're not
going to miss that but let's just see
what's going on with joe biden here
you know it comes from people all over
the country it's already occurring
all over the country all ideological
views
all backgrounds events of course
we are predictable some of them it comes
from all over except of course
from donald trump's white house and his
allies
you all knew was coming you could have
set your watches to it
donald trump has already started his
attacks
calling kamala quote nasty
whining about how she is quote mean
to his appointees it's no surprise
because whining is what donald trump
does best better than any president
american history
is anyone surprised just as a funny
little thing i don't i don't know if
this is true but
a couple of people i know in the
democratic party have said that some of
the
the people around biden do watch my
commentaries
and this is literally the language i
used in my commentary today i'm not
suggesting that they actually got it
from me but
what i do think is interesting is that
some of this language about trump being
a whiner has gotten to them and i think
it's important the water you drink
worried about your civil rights even
your basic right to dignity
which is under attack with this
administration kamala harris
has had your back and now
we have to have her back she's going to
stand with me in this campaign
and all of us are going to stand up for
her
on january 20th 2021
we're all going to watch senator harris
raise her right hand
and swear the oath of office let's hope
as the first woman ever
to serve in the second highest office in
america in this land
and then we're going to get to work
fixing the mess that president trump and
vice president pence
have created both at home and abroad
through four years of mismanagement and
coddling of terrorists
and thugs around the world not only will
america dig itself
out of this hole they put us in we're
going to build we're going to build back
we're going to build back better
we have a public health crisis while
he's in court trying to do away
with health care with more than 5
million reported infections 165
000 people dead and climbing as a
consequence of cover 19
and still months later
no real leadership or plan from the
president united states
how to get this pandemic under control
there won't be a plan no real help for
the states and local governments trying
to fill the vacuum
of leadership from the white house no
real help
for children and educators for small
businesses and front-line workers
that hold in their ones holding our
country together
instead he's issuing
executive orders and making promises
that in the end will defund the social
security system
while insisting that this virus will
disappear
the joe biden and kamala harris
administration
will have a comprehensive plan to meet
the challenge of covert 19
and turn the corner on this pandemic so
it's like nothing feels particularly
inspiring but it's like we
we we have two normal people who sort of
understand
just like basic things they understand
like when you have a medical crisis you
go to doctors
you don't come up with something on your
own and then think
what will get me to the next election
like it's it's a return to normalcy
responsibility
not as this president says it's not my
fault
the government the governor should thank
me more
as it all saying goes give me a break
we have an economic crisis with more
than 16 million americans
16 million still
out of work donald trump
is on track to break another record
on track to leave office with the worst
jobs record
of any american president of modern
history
but instead of doing the hard work of
meeting face to face
with congressional leaders democrats and
republicans in the white house like
every other president has done in a
crisis
to get americans the relief they need
and deserve
donald trump is on the golf course
if i told you this three years ago you
look at me like i was being crazy
he hasn't even now do you guys think
trump will deliberately wait till this
is over
or that he will start on time in order
to distract from this
we have a climate crisis that donald
trump refuses to even acknowledge
when he thinks about climate change all
here we hear is
the word hoax
the biden harris administration is going
to meet the climate crisis
protect the health of the american
public
and along the way we're going to deliver
one word
jobs good paying jobs
with a racial cri justice crisis donald
trump seeks only to inflame it
with his politics of racist rhetoric and
appeals to division
you know today is not only the day i'm
proud to introduce senator kamala harris
as the vice presidential nominee of the
democratic party
it's also the third anniversary of that
terrible day in charlottesville
remember remember what it felt like to
see those neo-nazis close your eyes
and those klansmen white supremacists
coming out of
fields carrying lighted torches
faces contorted bulging veins
pouring into the streets of historic
american city spewing the same
anti-semitic bile we heard in hitler's
germany
in the 30s remember how it felt
to see a violent clash ensue between
those
celebrating hate and those standing
against it
it was a wake-up call for all of us
as a country for me
it was a call to action my father used
to say
silence is complicity not original to
him
but he believed it at that moment i knew
i couldn't stand by and let donald trump
a man who went on to say when asked
about what he thought he said there were
very fine people on both sides
quote very fine people on both sides
no president of the united states of
america has ever said anything like that
see him continue to attack everything
that makes america america
i knew we were in the battle for the
soul of the nation
that's when i decided to run and i'm
proud now to have
senator harris at my side in that battle
because she shares with the same
intensity i do
for she's someone who knows what's at
stake
the question is for all americans to
answer
who are we as a nation what do we stand
for
and most importantly what do we want to
be
you know someone who knows
that the future of this country is
limited only by the barriers we place
on our own imaginations if you are just
joining us this is the first
joint biden harris event expecting
kamala harris momentarily we're also
standing by
for a bottom of the hour press briefing
with donald trump
unclear how the timing of that will uh
relate to the timing of this i also have
a bunch of stuff to play for you guys
and we'll see
uh when when we get to it possibilities
let me say it again
possibilities that's america
that's what sets this nation apart
is that everyone everyone
the ability for everyone and we mean
everyone to go as far
and dream as big as hard work and their
god-given ability will take them
when i agreed to serve as president
obama's running mate
he asked me a number of questions as
i've asked kama
but the most important was he said to me
what he asked me what i wanted most
importantly
i told him i wanted to be the last
person in the room before he made
important decisions that's what i asked
pamela
i asked common to be the last voice in
the room
to always tell me the truth which she
will
challenge my assumptions if she
disagrees
ask the hard questions because that's
the way we make the best decisions for
the american people
i got a chance to spend some time at my
home today
with kamal and doug and i want to thank
them i thank them them to thank them
publicly
for agreeing to join
and take this journey with chilling me
doug you're going to have to learn what
it means to be a barrier breaker
yourself in this job you're about to
take on
america's first second gentleman
and all their although they're not with
us here today
i want to thank ellen cole as well i had
a chance to speak to
doug's mom and dad and ellen cole
and uh we're going to get our kids
together
to let them know what what's coming our
my grandchildren are about the age of uh
their children i got to speak to them
my campaign has always been a family
affair every campaign i've run
so i've got some news for you
you're all honorary bidens
and here's the best part kamala you've
been an honorary biden for quite some
time
you know you know one of the most
interesting things about this is
when someone confronts donald trump and
criticizes donald trump publicly the way
kamala harris did to joe biden during
the debates
trump assails that person's character
and cuts them out
and tries to make them disappear
joe biden has selected as his running
mate like her politics or not the person
who
most fiercely confronted him during the
debates
that's fundamentally different
as if you needed me to tell you that but
that is the antithesis as i tweeted
yesterday
of the way trump does business when
people
challenge him winning the battle for the
soul of america
my fellow americans now let me introduce
to you
for the first time your next vice
president united states
kamala harris kamala floor is yours
what a crowd the crowd is just going
crazy
there's no crowd i'm kidding
there you go
thank you joe thank you thank you joe
as i said joe when you called me i am
incredibly honored
by this responsibility and i'm ready to
get to work
i am ready to get to work after the most
competitive primary in history
the country received a resounding
message
that joe was the person to lead us
forward
and joe i'm so proud to stand with you
and i do so mindful of all the heroic
and ambitious women before me whose
sacrifice
determination and resilience makes my
presence here today
even possible this is a moment
of real consequence for america
everything we care about our economy
our health our children the kind of
country we live in
it's all on the line we're reeling
from the worst public health crisis in a
century
the president's mismanagement of the
pandemic
has plunged us into the worst
economic crisis since the great
depression
and we're experiencing a moral reckoning
with racism and systemic injustice
that has brought a new coalition of
conscience
to the streets of our country demanding
change america is
crying out for leadership
yet we have a president who cares more
about himself
than the people who elected him a
president who is making
every challenge we face even more
difficult to solve but here's the good
news
we don't have to accept the failed
government
of donald trump and mike pence in just
83 days we have a
chance to choose a better
future for our country
so joe dr
biden thank you for the trust
you've placed in me jill i know
you will be an incredible first lady
and my husband doug and i are so
grateful
grateful to become a part of your
extended family
and ever since i received joe's call
i've been thinking
yes about the first biden
that i really came to know and that of
course is joe's beloved son
one of his beloved sons beau
in the midst of the great recession beau
and i spoke on the phone practically
every day sometimes multiple times a day
working together to win back billions of
dollars for homeowners
from the big banks of the nation that
were foreclosing
on people's homes and let me just tell
you about beau biden
i learned quickly that beau was the kind
of guy
who inspired people to be hey guys by
the way message to the moderators and to
people watching
we're not going to tolerate you know
racist comments
uh obviously misogynistic sexist slurs
of kamal hair so i'm dropping the
banhammer very very powerfully
and moderators you are fully deputized
and instructed to do the same
that they shared was incredible
to watch it was the most beautiful
display of the love between a father and
a son
and beau talked about how joe would
spend four hours every
day riding the rails back and forth from
wilmington to washington
so he could make breakfast for his kids
in the morning and make it home in time
to tuck them in bed each night all of
this
so two little boys who had just lost
their mom and their sister in a tragic
accident
would know that the world was still
turning
and that's how i came to know joe
he's someone whose first response
when things get tough is never to think
about himself
but to care for everyone else
he's someone who never asks why is this
happening to me
and instead asks what can i do
to make life better for you
this is actually interesting because
with all the focus on policy and
incompetence over the last few months
trump's just a terrible family man right
and
i'm not talking about using these sort
of weird standards of the evangelical
christian electorate about abortion and
whatever
trump just you get the sense he doesn't
even really like or connect with his
kids
his relationships are a mess like or
dislike joe biden's politics
i i prefer the guy who seems to know how
to get along
with with their spouse and their kids
over the guy who does it any day
daughter prepare for her school debate
or building legos with my godson
or hugging my two baby nieces
or cooking dinner sunday dinner
my family means everything to me
and i've had a lot of titles over my
career and certainly
vice president will be great but mamala
will always be the one that means the
most
and you know my mother and father they
came from
opposite sides of the world to arrive in
america
one from india and the other from
jamaica
in search of a world-class education
but what brought them together was the
civil rights movement of the nineteen
sixties
and that's how they met as students in
the streets of oakland
marching and shouting for this thing
called justice in a struggle
that continues today
and i was part of it my parents would
bring me to
strapped tightly in my stroller
and my mother shamala raised my sister
maya and me
to believe that it was up to us and
every generation of americans to keep on
marching
she tell us don't sit around and
complain about things
do something so i did something
i devoted my life to making real the
words
carved in the united states supreme
court
equal justice under law
and 30 years ago i stood before a judge
for the first time
breathed deep and uttered the phrase
that would that would truly guide my
career and the rest of my career kamala
harris
for the people the people
that's who i represented as district
attorney fighting on behalf of victims
who needed help
the people that's who i fought for as
california's attorney general
when i took on transnational criminal
organizations who traffic in guns and
drugs and human beings
and it's the people who i have fought
for as a united states senator
where i've worked every day to hold
trump officials accountable
hey by the way i just want to show you
guys something really funny
um if you look at the likes and dislikes
on this
live event this is the washington post
feed you'll see that
the trump bots disliking it are very
very present but
you know what you can't do anything
about is the fact that this is slightly
off screen so i apologize but
69 000 people what hold on a second
69 000 people are watching this
nothing that trump does uh and has done
for months
gets 69 000 people watching it so it's a
very very interesting sort of
proxy war that's being fought here but
my streams often have larger viewership
than trump's white house feeds of his
press briefings and there's 70
000 people watching this just through
the washington post have children that
are
hungry and tragically
more than 165 000 lives
that have been cut short many with loved
ones
who never got the chance to say goodbye
it didn't have to be this way six years
ago in fact
we had a different health crisis it was
called ebola
and we all remember that pandemic but
you know what happened then
barack obama and joe biden did their job
only two people in the united states
died
and trump still said obama should resign
that is what's called
leadership but compare that to the
moment we find ourselves in now
when other countries are following the
science trump pushed
miracle cures he saw on fox news
while other countries were flattening
the curve hydraulics that the vice would
just poof go away
quote like a miracle we need america so
when other countries
opened back up for business what did we
do
we had to shut down again and we didn't
yeah we should virus has impacted almost
every country but there's a reason
it has hit america worse
it's called any other advanced nation
mango menace
it's because of trump's failure to take
it
seriously from the start
his refusal to get testing up and
running
his flip-flopping on social distancing
and wearing masks
his delusional belief that he knows
better than the experts
all of that is reason and the reason
that an american dies of covid19 every
80 seconds how does pence debate her
like
how does he do it what does he do have
had to shut their doors for good
it's why there is complete chaos over
when and how to reopen
our schools mothers and fathers
are confused and uncertain and angry
about child care and the safety of their
kids at school
whether they'll be in danger if they go
or fall behind if they don't
trump is also the reason millions of
americans are now
unemployed he inherited the longest
economic expansion in history which he
took credit for
from barack obama and joe biden who he
criticized
and then like everything else he
inherited
he ran it straight into the ground
because of trump's failures of
leadership the middle school
our economy has taken one of the biggest
reversed out of all
the major industrialized nations
with an unemployment rate that has
tripled
as of today this is what happens when we
elect a guy
who just isn't up for the job quite
frankly
our country ends up in tatters
and so does our reputation around
the world but let's be clear
this election isn't just about defeating
donald trump or mike pence it's about
building
this country back better
and that's exactly what joe and i will
do
we'll create millions of jobs and fight
climate change
through a clean energy revolution bring
back
critical supply chains so the future
is made in america build on the
affordable care act
so everyone has the peace of mind that
comes with health insurance
and finally offer caregivers the dignity
the respect and the pay
they deserve will protect a woman's
right to make her own decisions about
her
own body root out systemic racism in our
justice system
and pass a new voting rights act
a john lewis voting rights act
that will ensure every voice is heard
and every voice is counted
the civil rights struggle is nothing new
to joe
it's why he got into public service it's
why he helped reauthorize the voting
rights act
and restore unemployment discrimination
and employment discrimination laws
and today he takes his place in the
ongoing story of america's march
toward equality and justice as only as
the
only as the only who has served
alongside the first black president
and has chosen the first black woman as
his running mate
but as joe always points out this
election
is about more than politics it's about
who we are
as a country and i'll admit over the
past four years there have been moments
when i have truly worried about our
future
but whenever i think that there
is a reason for doubt whenever i've had
my own doubts
i think of you the american people
the doctors and nurses and front line
workers who are risking
your lives to save others
the truck drivers and the workers in
grocery stores
in factories in farms working there
putting your own safety on the line
to help us get through this pandemic the
women and students taking
to the streets in unprecedented numbers
the dreamers and immigrants who know
that families belong together
the lgbtq americans who know that love
is love people of every age and color
and creed
who are finally declaring in one voice
that yes
black lives matter all across this
country a whole new generation
of children is growing up hearing the
cries
for justice and the chance of
hope you know for the people saying that
she's going to outshine
biden i don't know that it's all bad
right i mean
it's it's energy and i don't i don't
think there's any downside in this case
to it
so to everyone keeping up the fight you
are doing something you are doing
something great you are the heroes of
our
time and you are the reason
i know we are going to bring our country
closer to realizing its great promise
but to do it we'll need to work organize
and vote like never before
because we need more than a victory on
november third we need a mandate
that proves that the past few years do
not represent who we are
and to prevent trump's rigging claims to
be
joe likes to say that character is on
the ballot
and it's true when he saw what happened
in charlottesville three years ago today
he knew we were in a battle for the soul
of our nation
and together with your help that's a
battle we will win
earlier this year i said i do whatever
joe asked me to do
and so now i'm asking you to do the same
so visit joebiden.com to get involved in
this campaign
and vote because electing joe biden
is just the start of the work ahead of
us
isn't that the truth and i couldn't be
prouder to be by his side
running to represent you the people
thank you and may god bless the united
states of america
thank you whoa okay we're going to turn
that down to avoid getting hit with the
copyright claims the first
public event with joe biden and kamala
harris
uh a socially distant and safe event of
course in what looks to be a high school
gym of some kind
and um really i mean given the
circumstances all that one could uh
could could expect so we will see now if
and how donald trump responds to the
scheduled for an event
right now and we will see when he comes
out
uh here is kamala harris's husband doug
i forget his last name m hoff maybe
something like that
uh and of course dr jill biden standing
much more than six feet apart and isn't
it a beautiful thing to do that
uh doug coming out with a beautiful mask
and um this is the start this is the
start and i don't know how
mike pence by the way it's almost weird
to see
couples relating to each other normally
because we've become so used to the
bizarre nature of donald trump's
relationships with everyone around him
inclu
including melania um wearing masks of
course
and uh i mean listen guys i don't have
to tell you that
you guys can tell the difference between
what's going on here and what's going on
with donald trump so
we're standing by for donald trump i do
want to go over just a few things first
and foremost we missed
a level three hype train thank you to
everybody including bead juice and
circle hair
guy and spudnik and everybody who's
gifting
subscriptions and doing all of that
stuff love it number two
huge thank you to joe trinkle
and john paul decker who grabbed
memberships while
biden and kamala were speaking you guys
are new members number one and two as
you can see above my head on my website
joinpakman.com
and i do invite you to grab a membership
at joinpackman.com and then in the
meantime
things are getting extremely
ugly uh with the sam cedar race to a
million
situation by the way somebody made this
this is really good i promised i would
play it on today's
stream so let's take a look at it i
believe this is a mad men
remix uh take a look
i got a million of them a million good
so there it is shots very much fired
here um
i think i guess we have time to look at
oh this event is wrapping up which is
great
um i think we have time to look at this
is the latest shot across the bow from
sam cedar
i think a lot of you guys are going to
be very upset what's going on if you
don't know what's going on by the way
sam cedar and i are embroiled in a race
to a million subscribers on youtube
we are now at 935 000 and scheduled to
reach a million
on november 22nd my goal is november 3rd
i want to hit a million
on election day or before we are about
19 days off right now
so that's where we are and here let's
look at the craziness being said on sam
cedar's show this is ugly
bear at home too uh great seeing you on
msnbc over the weekend where can i find
the full episode online so i can send it
to my mom
also you're doing an impression of chris
hayes your cadence seem very familiar
i like the old matt on thursdays can you
interview david pakman on one of the
shows
uh we're in a big war right now with
david pakman i don't know if people know
that
so no way no way well
what if he gives you views by being on
gotta
see this stuff yeah jiu jitsu well you
know with the way pacman works he just
come on to steal subscribers
i know the way that he's what he's up to
how do you even do that
right now this is like i i wanna i've
been trying to hold off on this
but there's is this a desperate attempt
from sam because he's fallen 17 000
subscribers behind
fishy going on we're going to do a deep
deep dive into this
i welcome david pakman's subscriber
numbers i welcome and will cooperate in
an investigation
because you know normally
subscriber numbers go like this yeah
show it right show it
they normally go like this okay all
right that's the normal graph
of subscriber numbers but this is not a
normal channel it's also my notes to
myself here wait a second let me do this
let me tell you what has happened with
uh david pakman's numbers show it yeah
please
they have gone like this that's right
something very fishy is going on
that's thanks to you guys okay he's
saying
your behavior is fishy understand that
it's not a normal subscriber grab ben
shapiro's way to sabotage you he's like
oh give me getting in on there
well i don't know what it is but i will
tell you this
i suggested very lightly
very lightly that maybe there were bots
at play
and then all of a sudden i get a bunch
of emails
saying i'm not a bot but they oh
but they all are clearly sent from bots
look at let's play this yeah look at
that look at what what's going on
there that's a beautiful curve i'm sorry
folks like what is what is that about
sam's triggered by the beautiful girls
going on
i think somebody should investigate this
what was he covering
yeah let's hope he's more open to a
investigation than cuomo
i welcome an investigation let's hope so
we need an independent investigator i
welcome it we have a clip
of when he uh he as far as i can tell he
got his subscribers because he attacked
me
let's play this clip give me a break
give me a listen um
how do we even do this things are
getting really ugly
in the progressive media space right and
it pains me to have to do this today but
sam cedar right has casually
made a disgusting claim about the david
david pakman show
and fired a shot across the bow about
our recent surge of subscribers
claiming trigger absent any evidence
mind you
that somehow bots
that i have presumably used or paid for
are boosting our youtube subscriber
numbers
let me give you a little background last
week by the way this is all a joke just
because i know people will
this is all a joke okay last week okay
stop it the david pakman show him
now what is he what is he doing there
he's trying to play it off like it's all
a joke
well it's crazy when he's suing him huh
this well
i mean i'm i'm because people and so
listen i'm gonna stop it here
for people who are emailing me saying
they're really worried that this isn't
the right direction for
for us to be going in it is a joke it's
everything's fine and it's just a
friendly competition to get to uh
to get to a million subscribers okay
let's see fox news trump
let's see if fox is live anywhere yet
uh not seeing it trump
press briefing live oh i got all caps
there
oh fox news here it is uh okay
after chuck schumer here i think we will
get to uh being live in the room so it
is a joke
but in all seriousness i would love to
love to get to a million subscribers
before election day
there's 15 000 people watching on
youtube right now
please hit that subscribe button we
could get to 9 50 right now i mean
if ev i know not everybody's
unsubscribed but if if even a fraction
of you just hit subscribe now
we at least get to 9 40 right now so
please help us out and let's do that
okay other memes and things um
the the only thing i had was the one i
showed you so for people asking for
memes i don't really have any
others uh i do want to read a few super
chats if you're watching on youtube you
can always join the conversation with a
super chat
um adolfo madrid says david why not get
a co-host i'm doing a solo show yeah
it's just the the production logistics
are simpler and there's nothing
wrong with different formats but i'm
doing a solo show
skeppel says kamala rubbed a booger on
the podium
oh come on dude give me a break uh
jonathan bush says
treasonous trump is failing justin
akraski
says what's the likelihood joe drops out
within the first year and hands it off
to kamala very low but i wouldn't be
surprised if joe biden didn't run for
re-election and kamala did and in fact
i addressed that in a story about that
today um
musical aviator says dare trump paint
harris as defund
the police that would be interesting we
will see
um chakuseki says how many plants with
prepared republican talking points will
be scattered throughout president a gulf
twitter's manic briefing today
yeah yesterday i don't know if you
noticed but yesterday donald trump took
mostly friendly questions
and then sort of skulked off i actually
just published a clip to youtube called
trump trump struggling to speak as brain
fails it's sort of a review of
yesterday's
press briefing unknown prodigy says
isn't it nice to hear sanity behind the
mic
yeah absolutely other super chats coming
in um
a lot of people complaining about the
volume the volume's too high the
volume's too low
this is why i just have to do my own
thing um
danny asking if i'm sure there's another
trump event today yes we're watching it
right here
uh unknown prodigy says that should
really be the slogan
a return to normalcy not a bad idea
that indian dude says hello david let's
go 1 million subscribers it's too bad
sydney is now having a second wave
oh i see people asking about my goals on
twitch
listen i mean the i'm we're trying to
grow on twitch as well
um we have 43 000 followers on twitch
i've been on there for
uh i think it's 11 months and
um the immediate goal is 50 000. and
listen i mean i've been on youtube for a
decade so i understand we're not going
to have the same numbers on twitch that
we do on youtube
but i have to tell you on a percentage
basis i think we are doing
better on twitch let me just do the math
here let me pull in a calculator out of
nowhere
we've got about 15 000 whoa we need
number lock on
we've got about 15 000 people who
regularly watch my streams
out of 935 000 meaning that our average
youtube stream is about 1.6 percent of
my audience however
we've recently been often getting 3 000
of viewers live on twitch we only have
43 400 followers which means that
6.9 of my twitch following
watches a stream uh divided by 1.6
our engagement rate on twitch is more
than four times higher now if you don't
like math or simple arithmetic
boom we'll get that off the screen
forget about it okay
no forehead five head six head stuff uh
but in when we talk about per capita on
a per capita basis
our twitch streams actually do better
than youtube
you understand what i'm saying okay
people on twitch getting very excited
uh yeah but no in the immediate 50 000
is the goal on twitch it's certainly a
more modest goal than a million on
youtube but okay we've been on youtube
for a long time what do you want me to
say
um thanks to ethan marion who has just
made a pledge on patreon and you are
supporter number three today sometimes
we just count website members
but as you can see we're doing website
members and
patrons so either way it counts join
pacman.com with the coupon code if you
want
or just patreon we are counting both of
them
both of them count from the standpoint
of getting to 25.
jerry hickle says i'm not a biden or
harris fan
but their speech was such a huge
contrast to the current idiot very much
so
um satu gustafson says does anyone know
what became of the alleged
shooter what was that a stunt nothing on
the news yeah it is weird because there
was this shooting out near the white
house
on the i believe that was the monday
press briefing
and then we really haven't heard much
else about it it was very weird
charles bergenstein says joe biden
should resign the day after his second
year mark so kamala has the chance to be
president for 10 years
if she is re-elected twice there's an
idea
uh breaker19 says trump says he's done
the most for prison reform but the fair
sentencing act under obama got me out of
prison two years early baba bowie to you
okay merkin says hi from west palm
love the live trump fact checks
beautiful um
what else do we have going on a lot of a
lot of elements here being
inquired about daniel testface says who
do you think are top republican
presidential candidates in 2024
no no just no you're not i'm not going
to be goaded into that you know people
in 2017 were talking to me
about the dem primary and i said we have
a midterm
to deal with once we get past the
midterm i'll talk about the primary and
the last thing i'm going to talk about
now is republican candidates for 20
app just no no no no we have uh fish to
fry
that are much more present um
okay skeppel says actually i'm excited
to vote i'm yang gang
regardless of policy it's good to see
values bravery history representation
and balance it's progressive
timmy lunsford says your mode has
changed
mode do you mean mood it shows keep it
up
well part of why i'm doing better today
is we had
a completely master electrician master
that's all caps
master electrician here today in my
bunker
where i've been broadcasting this week
and um
we very powerfully fixed the elements of
electrical that weren't working this
week we had this crazy situation because
of an overly sensitive arc fault breaker
who care i mean electrical code this is
politics right but
electrical code in massachusetts very
strict
requires arc fault breakers and what
happens when i plug in
my laptop a second monitor
my voice processor a camera
a light it just it trips it trips and
everything's beautiful here there's no
risk of fire or anything so i
immediately got emerge i said we're
trying to do the david pakman show here
uh get an electrician here first thing
this morning and we did
and uh he replaced my arc fault breaker
with a regular breaker and now
everything is completely powered up
uh the of course we might we have a fire
risk now but at least things are uh
working properly so yeah i'm definitely
doing better
it's electricity guys you know i'm
trying to do a progressive podcast here
i have no electricity it's uh it's it's
crazy so now we're back on and
everything's going really well
curseaus gaming says dude i'm late to
this and they still flexing on the press
uh jess dudip says stop flooding your
subscriber base with steep discounts
you're training your fans to never pay
full price
this has been the downfall of many
retailers no
here's the difference when retailers
offer deep discounts this is actually
i've done
case studies on this at the graduate
school level
when retailers establish
regular and expected discounts and they
actually lose money
they end up being unable to compete with
online retailers in a race to the bottom
here's what you need to understand the
marginal cost
to me of a new member on my website
is for all intents and purposes zero
okay
if i get another 5 000 subscribers maybe
i need a slightly
more expensive web hosting plan okay
it's an extra 10 bucks a month or
whatever
but we can afford to offer the discounts
because
it's like a hundred percent profit you
understand what i'm saying right
um we we the the marginal uh
expense for every new member is almost
nil
because uh i think you understand i
think you understand the point that i'm
making here
so on that note let me just briefly i'm
going to take 30 seconds to mention this
okay our program our channel all of the
stuff we do the microphones the
connectivity
health insurance for employees
retirement
accounts i'm looking into for employ you
know all of this stuff it's funded by
website memberships period
we've got super chats we have patreon we
have
you know all these different things the
reliable consistent source
that nobody can take away because we
control it is people who grab
a membership at joinpakman.com plain and
simple that's it okay so here's my pitch
to you
we're doing this show period for
everybody
if you can't afford two bucks a month
don't sign up if you can't afford a
dollar 80 a month
please don't sign up i don't want
anybody's last dollar and we're here
providing what i believe is a valuable
public service but
if you value the work we do and you
think
a dollar eighty a month is reasonable
and you can afford that if you think two
bucks a month is reasonable
grab a membership at joinedpakman.com
the coupon code above my head 2020 now
will reduce will reduce um
the price all the way down to two bucks
a month or a dollar eighty a month if
you pay for the entire
year at a time um and
that is my uh that is sort of my pitch
to you and i will certainly
thank everybody who signs up now i'm
getting a report that something
is wrong with the website i don't think
that that's the case
because we have quadrupled the hosting
resources on the website
let me see if i can get that information
david pakman show website
um i believe
everything is fine yeah i don't think
anything i think everything's working
perfectly
but if anybody wants to tell me
otherwise oh no
is there a bad gateway situation going
on oh my god that would be terrible
oh my goodness there actually does
appear to be some kind of website issue
oh dear god that is so embarrassing i'm
gonna have to go in and
and uh try to get that dealt with that's
horrible
oh my god do you think it could be
bogged down i i
actually don't think so i'm gonna see
what we can get going here
um that would just be terrible imagine
all these people trying to sign up and
nobody can
all right let me send a message over to
our web person
what how embarrassing is that guys how
embarrassing is that
uh okay let's pull her in
uh let's see here hey guys we are
getting a 502
bad gateway on the website and it is
troubling
okay very good um and then i'll just do
a reset as well
on my end of the server and see if that
gets us back up and running what a
disaster i mean that is just what that
is terrible terrible timing
my hosting service is gonna uh hear from
me
uh i'm gonna go i'll karen on them if
you can imagine that okay we're gonna
get it all fixed up
um let's see other super chats that are
coming in chakuseki says i can't wait
for kamala to beat on trump like an
orange-skinned bongo drum just like how
she punished boofing beer boy kavanaugh
i found it so funny that yesterday um
donald trump criticized kamala for how
she
destroyed um uh brett kavanaugh when
it's like that was fantastic she did an
amazing job
um and that shows that shows me
that uh she is probably going to
absolutely crush mike pence
during a debate and i very much look
forward to it um
i mean it's it's i i very much look
forward to seeing that and it's a it's
something that we should be cheering
people saying the website is back up i
did reset it
um i am going to uh
just launch live chat with our hosting
support
um get oh i've got to mute that though
that's going to be really annoying
getting 502 bad gateway
on our website please help
yeah some of this should get everything
get everything back up and running but
yeah it looks like 70 people are all of
a sudden on the website so hopefully
it'll resolve
but we uh we will continue to work on
that
other super chats coming in pat needham
asks what is our web hosting plan
we have an eight gig sort of like
cloud-based uh you know it
scales relative to the need and it's
really it's really worked pretty well
um so i'm not i'm not displeased
with the website um services
super oh let's do some twitch stream uh
messages eric rothschild says over on
twitch
sam cedar won't release his tax returns
as they provide
evidence he's colluding with brian tyler
cohen
to steal your youtube subscribers
um i doubt that that's true
but we will look into it we will look
into it
uh okay good now i've got an actual
i've got an actual tech support person
working on the website now
and people are reporting a 503 error as
well
so that should be back up and running
very soon but it looks like it's it's
like partially back up and running
because um al allman just signed up
and is new member number four so it
looks like we've got a partially working
website it's kind of embarrassing
um when the website goes down as we are
trying to
rally the troops for memberships but i
think they're going to have everything
working very very quickly
okay uh i wanted to do a couple other
twitch messages vapenesh says time to
end the malarkey in november
couldn't agree more brunebreed
says get the prime subscriptions in
gogogonzox has subscribed with prime
tai schneides has subscribed at tier one
which is very exciting um
the super chats continue to pour in like
a faucet
devin nunes's cal matthews says they're
saying harris
is a criminal justice reform missed
on mainstream media okay i don't know
exactly what you mean
gabe says david did you see trump
donated 6 000 to harris's ag campaign
when she was running yes and i discussed
that on today's bonus show actually and
i had a lot to say about that
uh jason nadal says what do you think
warren's role will be in the biden
administration now that she's no longer
a vp pick
i think elizabeth warren would be
qualified to be secretary of education
secretary of the treasury probably
commerce secretary as well i
actually think that there's probably
five or six reasonable
uh positions for uh kamala harris
i'm sorry for uh elizabeth warren now
that kamala harris
is the vp nominee um and i maybe
maybe i'll do an entire segment about it
as well vanessa rose says could trump
declare a state of emergency just before
the election to postpone the election
i don't believe so we've never had a
federal election postponed
i don't think it's going to happen i
don't believe it's going to happen
irefon fazal says hey david what helps
you more sending money through super
chat or through your website listen
on our website we keep the highest slice
of every payment i'm not allowed to say
how much youtube slice is off
i'm not allowed to do that as you
understand but what i can tell you is
we keep the most uh on website
subscriptions that i know for sure
um bernie supporter this is e bernie
supporter voting biden
why is everyone excited to see kamala
versus pence
but okay with biden hiding in the
basement not debating trump it's bizarre
i i don't think that that is true uh
i just don't expect any fireworks at
biden versus trump
i think much like with um
bernie versus biden where a lot of
people were expecting
biden will implode or this is going to
be a groundbreaking and nothing really
happened
i don't think it's going to be that
notable biden versus trump i think
kamala versus pence
could be just a brutal brutal uh
drubbing
and as matt chavez is asking did mike
pence get mother's permission to debate
harris yeah
is he even allowed to be without a
chaperone debating kamala harris that's
actually a really good question
i don't know the answer i don't know the
answer it's a
very important thing to uh figure out
steven mnuchin came in here is larry
kudlow
uh the guy behind kudlow i never i
forget who that is is that scott
something i don't remember who that guy
is
we are now expecting donald trump very
very soon
we are live now over on the white house
feed and this is my preferred feed it is
a few seconds behind but that's okay i
will refresh just to get us as close as
possible
um in comes larry kudlow the other guy
behind him and another photographer so
we should be pretty close
uh to the start here i expect many
questions about kamal harris i expect
many attacks on kamala harris as well
and uh we will see how that all
goes david adams asks via super chat
yang for possible us secretary of labor
what are your thoughts that would be
interesting i don't think that he would
be a bad
uh selection necessarily mike says now
that sam
sader has pretty much lost the race to a
million i think your next goal
should be to overtake a real challenge
tyt it would probably first of all i
don't think sam has lost
we still have a long way to go um but i
think overtaking t i mean listen tyt is
a different
infrastructure you know tyt has i think
it's like 70 employees
they're on a completely different level
from the standpoint of business
so i don't know that that would be
possible
um tim carlson says love the show sweden
is behind
biden harris jorgen asks says hi david
greetings from norway again do you think
a potential vaccine from a u.s company
before november 3rd could get him
reelected
i know that if we get a vaccine that was
developed in the u.s
before the election donald trump will
try to take credit for it and
um it may work it may not we have to
prevent it from happening
uh okay i'm hearing back from uh hosting
support and we're trying to
to get the website running very
powerfully
um let me see here i'm gonna send an
update
to my web people
and here is donald trump so let's listen
now to that
thank you very much
appreciate you being here
and good evening as we continue to
confront the
china virus we're rebuilding america's
economy like
nobody thought possible actually we're
doing incredibly well stock markets up
almost 300 points again today
while our economy is performing
significantly better than
europe which people have to understand
very
strongly it's performing better than any
market anywhere in the world actually
meaningless at the same time europe has
experienced a 40
higher excess mortality than the
united states and i will say that
doesn't even make sense
a significant number we're working with
europe on their difficulties and we are
going to help them all the way we're
doing very well as you know the vaccines
and the a lot of sweet communics but
think of that we have the strongest
economy
performing economy in the world we're up
uh
i think it's nine trillion dollars since
march nine trillion dollars in value
that's a that's a number that nobody's
ever heard of before it's also a number
that's meaningless to the average
american's day-to-day life
about a 50 number since
march which is incredible so it's nine
trillion dollars it's almost 50
in fact i think it went above 50 today
with the 300
point increase and it's so we're doing
much better than europe significantly
and at the same time europe has
experienced a 40
higher excess mortality than the united
states
i just want to mention because another
number of judges were
approved recently will be probably over
300 judges federal judges including
court of appeals judges approved by the
end of my first term
and other than they when they added new
judges
into somebody's term which happens
seldom
but we have more than any uh there's a
record
nobody's ever seen in anything like this
in one term so
horrible people 300 federal judges
and that's court of appeals judges and
that's just
in the first term it's probably
over 300 which is pretty amazing
the stock market's rebound signals a
v-shaped recovery
stronger than our competitors
anywhere in the world stronger if you
look you'll see
exactly what we have we
we lead the world japan a second
but in terms of uh this is what happens
when no one understands math statistics
uh
you know come on guys europe united
kingdom japan
china hong kong the united states is
leading the world
remember also that when it's an increase
from the low the more you decline
the easier it is to show an increase
economic contraction in the united
states has
been far less severe than it was with
our peers and peer nations
and you see that right there there's the
united states
and that's despite the fact that we've
done more testing than any other nation
in the world so this one's deceptive
because
it goes it it doesn't relate to
coronavirus
this is so stupid oh my god i i feel
like an idiot even having to explain why
this is dumb
we're helping other countries but
despite all of these factors
the shallowest contraction which is a
big deal
i'm sure you'd love to put them in your
various
media outlets i know you want to get
that out if you want to leave the room
early and do that that would be fine can
you
is that a joke but it would be nice to
report it the rapid recovery of
homebuilders
sentiment points to massive new
construction and we are
doing massive amounts of construction of
new homes and that's because people have
tremendous confidence this is where we
went
and the housing market has quickly
rebounded we were at a record and now
we're going to be at a record again very
shortly
those numbers are incredible so we are
actually experiencing a ddos attack
right now we have
three people working on it on our
website and uh clearly somebody not
wanting people to sign up for
memberships a direct attack on the david
pakman show we've dealt with it before
we have people working on it but we are
under a ddos attack as we speak
over the last three months 65 percent
automobile demand
and we're anticipating that that's going
to go up even further but that's
more than any anybody else
the manufacturing sector remember
manufacturing is dead according to the
past
administration of obama and by
manufacturing is dead you'd need a magic
wand well you don't need a magic wand
you need
competence and capability the
manufacturing set
sector is booming and the production
index is at the highest reading since
october of 18 which is uh
was a an extraordinary period of time
and there we are that's pretty good
these are numbers that nobody has seen
until just recently and now that is just
coming out
these are numbers that are leading
i guess stock market people they're very
smart people
i know many of them and they're seeing
things that they don't even believe
so the manufacturing sector is booming
yeah they don't believe it that's right
and the production
index is at its highest rating in a long
long time
the economy generated over nine million
jobs
in the last three years a record by far
and 12 million more jobs than experts
predicted
so this is so deceptive guys
so this is this makes it
seem like we're ahead of where we were
right
but look look at these numbers this is
minus 22.5
this is plus 7.5 i mean this is just so
stupid but i think people that follow
trump might fall for this
you look at that and that's a record and
it's a record for the quarter
we had over 9 million substantially more
than 9 million jobs
what is this just wild numbers about our
economy and how it's coming back
it's coming back very strongly it's
coming back
at a level that's far greater than
anybody anticipating imagine taking
pictures of that
and we're very proud of that i give a
lot of credit to all of our people steve
and larry and
uh we'll be uh talking about it if you
have any questions on it i
shouldn't have any questions uh i didn't
i didn't like you lose 22 million
and then you gained seven and you're
like we've never gained seven so quickly
before those charts
who did the economy junior i think let's
see i don't know we'll find that out for
you but
it wasn't us we took those the pictures
took those numbers from
somebody where did you get those numbers
larry who cares
jobs reporting pls channel jobs report
through july okay everybody has that
everybody needs the democrats have
abandoned the american
people over the simple subject of
politics
chuck schumer and nancy pelosi are
holding the american people hostage over
money for their radical left-wing
agenda that the country doesn't want and
won't accept
for example they've asked for a
ridiculous 3.5
billion dollars that's billion 3.5
billion dollars
for universal mail-in voting a system
riddled by fraud and corruption you just
look at what happened with the carolyn
maloney race they should do that race
over by the way yep
i think remember that no fraud is even
alleged in that one
having fits about that race when you
look at the ballot
the ballots that are missing and the
ballot frauds nobody knows what's going
on with that race and yet they declared
her
a winner so her opponent i don't know
what's happened over the last 24 hours
but her
opponent is rightfully going a little
bit crazy
and then you look at what happened in
virginia where they have 500
000 applications sent out at random to
people
that have no idea what happened and they
admitted they made a mistake and
many were sent to dead people men were
sent to
number were sent i guess two that at
least two three four dogs
dogs dogs one was sent to a cat
they're sent all over the place that was
in virginia and paterson new jersey
they had a massive amount of voter fraud
voter fraud and it's been a
disaster paterson new jersey has been
total disaster that's universal i
actually have a
uh uh i have a cougar that got
three but three ballots didn't fill any
of them out though gave two to a
mountain lion
voting so they want 3.5 billion dollars
for universal mail-in voting for the
country where you have
hundreds of millions of voters they
can't do a little race with 20
000 people now they want to take it
countrywide mail-in voting it's going to
be the greatest
fraud in the history of elections when
you always
talk about russia russia russia china
iran on voting your biggest problem is
going to be with the democrats not with
china and russia and iran your biggest
time is going to be with the democrats
but now the democrats they want 3.5
billion dollars think of it
but now that they're unwilling to
approve a bill that gives all of
that money of course we would never
approve an amount like that
and they also won 25 billion dollars
additional for the post office steve
25 billion for the post office so the
post office can handle this vast
amount of ballots that are being sent at
random all over the place
they have no idea where they're going so
they want 25 billion and they want
think of this they want 3.5 billion
would you say that's enough to cover it
i think we could do it for less
right i think we could do it for less
but they want just to update everybody
on the website we have identified
two uh spam addresses
based in india brute forcing our entire
website to prevent you from signing up
for a membership we have three very
powerful resources in place
right now and are hoping to have the
website up very soon
great people in the post office
incredible people but they've had very
bad leadership for many years so
we'll get it straightened out but they
turned down
this bill you guys think it's sam cedar
you think he he would go this low you
think so
the items that nobody in their right
mind would approve
so they want 25 billion for the post
office they went 2.5
3.5 billion dollars for universal
mailing 3.5
billion those both seem like good places
to invest money
and the bill's not going to happen
because they don't even want to talk
about
it because we can't give them the kind
of ridiculous things that they want that
have nothing to do with the
china virus has nothing at all to do
with china virus much of what they're
asking for
so therefore they don't have the money
to do the universal
mail-in voting so therefore they can't
do it i guess right are they going to do
it
even though they don't have the money
they're asking for the three this is
trump's trick
trump's trying to withhold the money so
that they don't do it.5 billion
they're asking for 25 billion for the
post office so they can
do this i guess in other things at 25 i
would hope it would be a lot of other
things too
but therefore verbally they don't have
it
they don't have the money to do the
universal mail-in
votes it'll be the greatest rigged
election in history it'll be
the greatest fraud ever perpetrated
other than perhaps what they did to my
campaign where they started my campaign
obamacare you know what it is everybody
else
and they got caught let's see what
happens this will be one of the greatest
frauds in history
so they're admitting that they want 3.5
billion
and they're not going to do
a deal that's good for the american
people therefore they're not going to
get the 3.5 billion therefore
they can't do the universal i hope
people understand
i've not been replaying the same three
minutes he's gone through this exact
same thing three times now
mail-in vote it's very simple how are
they going to do it if they don't have
the money to do it
the democrats are also holding up money
for schools and hospitals and small
businesses
and state and local governments they
tried to stop
americans from getting unemployment
insurance and protection from
evictions which is why i took this
decisive action
and i did executive orders which are now
in full force in effect
and they're going forward i signed a
directive to provide a total of 400
of additional support for americans who
are unemployed
due to the china virus that's 400
more than the democrats have provided
remember that that's 400 more than the
democrats have provided
nancy and chuck haven't provided
anything
and remember this president obama
when we had a problem
pretty big problem a very big problem
you know what he gave 25 he gave 25
bucks
what so now they say well we want to
give 500 or we want to give
they don't want to give they don't give
anything they're not doing anything
but president obama and biden
sleepy joe gave 25 what is he talking
about
and they'll complain oh we want to give
more well we're giving 400
dollars and that's now in the works and
that'll be getting out to the people
soon steve okay
remember that 25 is what they gave the
last time
25. i want to make it unmistakably clear
that i'm protecting people from
evictions
they didn't want to do that the
democrats didn't want to do that's not
true
protection from evictions people getting
evicted because democrats submitted a
proposal
two months ago so the china virus
whatever you want to call it we have
20 now we're up to 21 different names
21 names all we know is it came out of
china and it shouldn't have they should
have stopped it
under my executive order hud hhs and cdc
have been directed to ensure renters and
homeowners that they can stay
safely in their homes they're not going
to be evicted they are not going to be
evicted
and those letters have already been sent
out steve so
you'll make sure that i'm providing a
payroll tax
holiday to all americans earning less
than 100 000
per year meaning bigger paychecks for
working families through the end of
2020 that's a tremendous
amount of money that's being supplied
and given to families tremendous
the democrats didn't want to do a
payroll tax they thought it was
too much money i guess or it would make
businesses too successful they don't
want to see success
they certainly don't want to see it
before the election they certainly don't
want to see
the kind of graphs and charts that you
saw up there they don't because they say
they can't win
with that kind of success they can't win
they have to get used to it
remember we've already gotten three
trillion dollars in stimulus so
they should have probably negotiated a
little bit differently
maybe they should have asked for all of
this before
we got most of the money and we gave it
out a lot of it to the people
what on earth is he talking about win
the election when i win the election i'm
going to completely and totally forgive
all deferred payroll taxes
that's buying votes without in any way
shape or for understand what he's doing
this is important
he's def he wants to defer the payroll
taxes now
but he'll forgive them if you vote him
back in if you don't vote him back in
those deferred taxes will be due when
you file your taxes next year
it's literally buying votes hurting
social security that money is going to
come from the general fund
we're not going to touch social security
i said from day one
that we're going to protect social
security
and uh and then understand that he's
saying he'll permanently cut funding to
social security while staying out of the
other side of his mouth he'll protect
to protect our people and social
security is one of the things that will
be protected
pre-existing conditions will be
protected medicare will be protected
but social security will be totally
protected under me under them it will
not be protected because that's a lie
we'll have a stock market crash the
likes of which you've never seen
that's a lie your taxes will be doubled
and tripled
and your regulations obviously you know
if you're already paying 36
federal how do you even triple that it
goes over 100 percent these are
you only the most ignorant people would
fall for this
go through the roof which is what was
causing the problems with the country in
the first place student loans
i signed a directive providing relief to
student borrowers
not their fault that they can't go to
college
will be deferring payments on student
loans at zero interest until further
notice so
we're going to take care of our students
it almost seems like he doesn't believe
this
they got hit like everybody else so i
will be
deferring payments on student loans at
zero interest until further notice
and the payroll tax will be terminating
the payroll tax
now no he just said he's protecting
social security now he says he will
permanently reduce the funding to social
security
after i hopefully get elected we'll be
terminating
the payroll tax why not do it now
anywhere from 5000 to even more per
family
and also great for businesses and great
for jobs
a lot of people will be very happy to
hear that a lot of the great certainly
conservative
economists will be great to have they
think that's the greatest thing we can
do that's better than the payments
that's better than anything else
but it's a lot of money and it's uh it's
going right directly to the people
and it goes there very easily but it
also creates stronger
companies to employ the people so we
will be
on the assumption i win we are going to
be
quite an assumption in the payroll tax
after the beginning of the new year
today i met with parents students
teachers and health experts to discuss
the
vital importance of safety and
safely reopening america's
schools this evening i'll outline the
common sense recommendations that should
guide schools as
they reopen with precautions
we want to be very
wide as we race toward the competition
and the completion we're competing with
others but i'm not completing
competing with anyone we just want to
have a vaccine we have we're dealing
with other countries
and we want them to do well we're giving
them whatever information they need
we're all working towards something that
will
happen will happen before the end of the
year maybe
even sooner but we're looking for
that responsible path forward to shelter
those at highest risk while
allowing those at lower risk to resume
work and school
and play football go play football
i spoke to some of the great football
players college players
i was muted guys i'm sorry i'm sorry
this is this is that what i was saying
was that's the same list
uh from march that's where we are today
same list from march
classic people i got to speak to
athletes
leaders they want to play football let
them play
what a [ __ ] show let them play and
they'll please don't cancel me they feel
safer in the field and they do
uh walking around and doing nothing
so hopefully that will happen and
hopefully when they play football
they will proudly stand for the national
anthem and
imagine that proudly stand and and
respect the american flag
or at least i'm not watching i can't
speak for others but based on
what i see now and based on what i'm
looking at with respect to the nba at
this point
no one cares about what he thinks agree
with me yeah so we want
people we would like to request people
you stand for request
standing the flag and for the
national anthem right in the months
since the virus arrived
now again i mentioned this before they
never used to televise the anthem during
nba games anyway so clearly
you know trump is hearing that players
are kneeling but they don't even
televise that part like health issues
the united states has the largest
nursing home
and assisted living home population
in the western world by far nearly half
of all of the deaths from the china
virus in the united states have occurred
in nursing homes and long-term care
facilities
the median age of those who succumb to
the virus is 78 years old
these findings underscore that all
americans must continue to apply extreme
vigilance in protecting
insulin population and those with
chronic conditions
outcomes are very different for younger
americans without
serious health issues tremendously
different
they can often expect mild or moderate
symptoms or
even no symptoms whatsoever
they have very strong immune systems
we've learned even more so than we ever
thought in a typical year approximately
five times as many americans under the
age of 65
die from heart disease as have so far
been lost to the coronavirus
from the same age group that's an
interesting statistic
bless blessedly children appear
to face the lowest risk of all
it's 99.995 percent of all fatalities
fatalities look at that 99. 0.95
that is extremely close to a hundred
percent
of all fatalities are fatalities twice
children often um
we're getting plasma the way this is
going things are
incredibly rare very very very rare
fatalities those that do face
complications often have underlying
medical conditions
in each of the last five years the flu
resulted in more
yosemites are at particularly high risk
of fatilities
if they don't get plasma loss thus far
to coronavirus by far
the flu the flu does kill young people
given these considerations we believe
many school districts can now reopen
safely provided they
implement mitigation measures and health
protocols to protect families
protect teachers and protect students
all
families should be empowered to make the
decision
that is right for their own
circumstances
this is especially important if a child
has underlying health conditions or
lives with a parent or grandparent
who is at a high risk
and one of the things we'd like to do is
when we make payment to
schools because we spend a lot of money
on schools we'd like to make the payment
directly to the
student or to the child
and that would mean to the parents
essentially but to the child we want to
follow the child
so that if the school is closed the
family can go to another school
there's an idea to defund public schools
huh no no
no missed opportunity to make that
payment rather than paying a school
that's close would rather pay
directly we're following the child where
the child goes
maybe look at paying teachers that's
another idea too and then the
family can take care of the cost and
we're trying to get that approved too
but the democrats don't like doing
anything unless it means
doing for the union which controls
nancy and controls chuck 100
and i have nothing wrong with the union
i have great respect more than
very few people do i respect more than a
great teacher
tremendous talent they're really under
under-appreciated no greater respect
than sending kids right back to school
maybe to infect the teachers huh
ones are among the most important people
we have
this country but
and they'll be great at other they'll be
greater charter schools and
they'll be great at when we talk about
school choice which we'd like to see
so that parents can take their children
to
the school of their choice that's
something we want we think it's very
important especially
in the minority communities they want it
so badly
african-american hispanic american
asian-american they want it so badly
but the desperate the two people i
mentioned
nancy and chuck they're totally
controlled by the heads of the union
i think the teachers like us a lot we're
taking care of our teachers we want to
take care of our teachers
but we cannot indefinitely stop 50
million american children from
going to school and harming their mental
physical emotional and academic
development and inflicting long-term
lasting damage
i heard a gentleman today a great person
some of you are at that meeting
from harvard say that every year is ten
thousand dollars it's uh
people they lose a tremendous amount of
money in the future
mentioned ten thousand dollars
and i think he was talking about on a
yearly basis they lose a lot
by every year of education that they
lost every year they gained
they gained 10 000 and when you have
right but this is just in general like
having more education
usually leads to higher salary but that
we're that that's not actually
what we're talking about here so we want
to get our students in the classroom
the american academy of pediatrics
has released guidance recommendation
that schools reopened they said reopen
it said quote
lengthy time away from school an
associated
interruption of supportive services
often results
in social isolation making it difficult
for schools to identify and address
important learning deficits
he seems confused the doctors also
warned about the risk of increased
abuse i would substitute depression
and suicide suicide
the national education association
recently stated despite
the momentous efforts of educators
during the pandemic
online learning has never been an
effective replacement for
in-person learning and support i hope
everybody understands we're talking
about online for
like one more semester that's what we're
talking about the idea being
people will start getting vaccinated and
in the spring we can
start to return to normality we're not
talking about ending education here he's
acting like we're saying we maybe
shouldn't educate kids anymore
studies estimate that school closures
last
spring caused the average student to
fall 50
behind in math and roughly 35 percent
in reading compared to a typical year
think of that cause the average student
to fall 50 percent behind in math how
far behind is trump
compared to being at the school being
with your teachers being in a classroom
we've learned that we've learned that
learning from a laptop
is not great and frankly we've also
learned that
telehealth a little unrelated but
it's up 35 000 and it's been
incredible thirty five thousand percent
we'll check that number larry but that's
it yeah check the number so guys
learning through a laptop is very
dangerous
medicine through a laptop is great and
should be encouraged
okay period of time with the with the
plague
with the plague coming in and those are
two things we know school closures
harm low income students the most
because they have less access to high
quality remote learning
they don't have computers and less
resources for
academic support all schools should be
making plans to resume in-person
classes as soon as possible
to support the reopening of america's
schools we provided 13 billion dollars
in
elementary and secondary schools toward
the
cares act and karezak funding we're
giving cares
act funding the vast majority of which
remain
available for states to use
so a tremendous amount of money 13
billion dollars
that's the cares act funding and we're
giving a large portion of that for
states to use today i'm pleased to
announce that we will
provide up to 125 million
reusable masks to various
school districts all around the country
hopefully schwab's my administration
also stands ready to deploy cdc teams
to support schools that are opening
and schools that need help in safety and
in order to safely reopen
finally today my administration is
highlighting general recommendations for
all schools and guidance to protect
high-risk
teachers and students we're working very
very closely with
many of the schools and school districts
throughout the country
they include the following to ensure all
students
teachers and staff understand the
symptoms
of the china virus you might remember he
put this up 10 minutes ago
um is he does he have two copies of the
speech today like he's
he's repeated portions two to four times
we just had this up on the screen with
the exact same introduction
and ensuring that hand hand-washing
facilities are widely available
throughout the school
and for the most part schools have been
very good at that
minimize large indoor gatherings
hold large gatherings outdoors whenever
possible
maintain high standards of hygiene and
ventilation within the classrooms
including keeping windows and doors open
whenever possible
and running fans and air conditioning
units
whenever possible require students
teachers and staff
to socially distance around
high-risk individuals and socially
distance whenever possible
in any event encourage the use of masks
when
social distancing is not possible
post instructions regarding hygiene and
social distancing all over the school
and all around the school
we encourage schools to adopt these
measures
we've been working with so many of them
and to the best of my knowledge
virtually every one of them agrees to do
that
while we're also providing high-risk
teachers and students options to engage
in
distance teaching or learning
we're working on that also because i
said it was bad
age students also continue to be one of
the lowest risk
demographics more than 99.8
of the deaths from this horrible disease
the invisible enemy we call it occur in
people
over 24 years of age think of that 99.8
percent
occur in people over 24 years of age for
this reason
it could be safer for them to live at a
school rather than
live with their older parents or
grandparents
we've got to go to school we've got to
open up we've got to open up our schools
and open up our businesses
and a lot of it has been open but we can
do better
as we move forward the number of cases
is not by any means the most important
metric to focus on because the fact is
we have more cases because we have far
more testing than any country in the
world there's no country that's even
close
we've done more testing and better
testing than any country and many of
these countries that
the media was putting up as a shining
example of
success they're right now in massive
outbreaks you see what's going on in
many of the countries that you
constantly mention far more important is
who the virus is infecting right that's
why our strategy and attention
are focused on preventing the cases that
are
most likely to require hospitalization
or result in death those that afflict
the elderly and those with certain
underlying health conditions
all the while acting to prevent hospital
overcrowding
if you look at some of the states that
had a
flare-up recently they're all doing very
well florida is going down
rapidly i want to give a lot of credit
to the governors
florida's going down and arizona
is going down way down
they've done a fantastic job california
as you know
is going down and many other locations
it's doing very well in many locations
are
really uh he already did this portion as
well i mean this is this is
the most bizarre performance yet that
we've seen him do
large portions of the united states
those advocating for a never-ending
blanket nationwide lockdown which nobody
is
have no answer for what it would do to
the mental physical and social health of
millions of american children and people
yeah i'm not running this on a loop
parents where
they have to stay home with their
children because and they lose their
work and they lose their job
because their children isn't at school
they have to have their children
isn't at school isn't it their children
isn't at school they don't trust people
a society must put the health and safety
of our
children first a man who has
the respect of everybody he's highly
respected by me and
kylie anybody on this subject
he's just the expert dr scott atlas is
here from stanford
that's it he's been working with us for
a period of time and i thought it would
be great he was
saying things to me the other day i said
it would be great if you could tell that
to the media
so this is the first time i've shared
the platform
and uh it's an honor to do so scott is
truly uh
he's a brilliant man he's a wonderful
man and he cares about this subject very
much and
i'd like to ask scott to come up please
and say a few words
this is bizarre huh
thank you mr president uh obviously a
great honor to be here and
uh great honor to serve this president
who's
really focused on the very important
parts of the pandemic
and odd guy huh i'm new here i'm just
sort of
getting involved but i want to thank you
and the vice president
and the entire team the task force team
and who is this all the people who are
not very visible really for working so
hard
uh these people are working 24 7. and uh
it's it's quite amazing uh and i think
the
we today we had a fantastic event that
i'll just mention on opening the schools
because the president's priority is to
open the schools and open them safely
and have parents have the options to
either use open schools or do whatever
they can to eventually
get back to open schools including any
kind of hybrid
or other arrangement they may want to do
it was a great event
we had a group of fantastic parents
teachers medical experts
and it went very well and so i i won't
spend a lot of time up here but thank
you very much and i hope i can help out
in some way
thank you steve thank you
you mentioned the executive orders that
you signed are we now
unlikely to see any more stimulus
legislation before the election
we're giving 400 and we
are in constant touch with governors
also who
they'll be making perhaps a contribution
they have options they can do it or they
don't have to do it i think most of them
will do it
we're also doing a payroll tax cut which
is a massive number that's a very big
number
and that's a number that's bigger than
any of the numbers we talked about
and the beauty of that is it it really
incentivizes
companies and because it's both a
company cut and a
a employee cut so that much
really very much incentivizes people
to uh go back to work and work hard and
the company to hire people back
and we've had some of the great economic
minds saying that's the most important
cut that would be the best cut you could
do we couldn't get the democrats to even
think about
agreeing to it it's not the democrat way
i guess
because it just seems that whether it's
larry kudlow or
any of your many friends that's the one
they wanted the most would you say larry
and so we're doing that and that was
never even really discussed because that
was
taken off the table by the democrats
immediately and this is every week every
week you get a check or a month or
bi-weekly this is
a major amount of money that you're
getting
directly so it's really uh you know it's
a very big number it's a very
substantial number excuses
don't forget this is an addition to the
to the four hundred dollars
and uh this is a a
big number and now at the end of the
year
the assumption that i win i'm going to
terminate the payroll tax right buying
which is
another thing that some of the great
economists and crushing social security
of course will be
paying into social security through the
general fund
and it works out very nicely
if biden would win he wouldn't do that
because he's going to double and triple
everybody's taxes
he's going to compose that one and as
you know he's also going to
quadruple regulations he wants to call
regulations on
one of the reasons that we had the kind
of numbers and
and big bounces that you've seen i mean
we closed it up we saved millions of
lives and now we open it and we bounce
right back where we were
lying it looks like we'll be bouncing
right back where we were
but we have 11 unemployment and we're
down still like
i mean we're even after this quarter
we'll be down 20 gdp or
15 it's crazy with his new partner
kamala will uh if you think he's going
to put it all back
but many times more i mean they want to
increase regulations and that's just
going to drive
companies out and it's going to drive
people out it's going to drive them to
other countries and it's going to make
us
not competitive with other countries
please
i like to highlight a kind of odd
situation in the last hour or so if you
googled antifa.com it would take you
straight to
joe biden's website his official
campaign website
odd situation we don't know who's behind
that
but it raises an interesting leadership
question
should joe biden the democrat party
kamala harris should they
publicly denounce it raises no
leadership questions that somebody
redirected a url
they should i think they're afraid to
it's
in my book it's virtually a part of
their campaign antifa
uh the democrats act like gee i don't
know exactly what that is take a look at
uh
portland take a look at any place you
want to take a look at
they're all over the place the world is
laughing at us guys
that the world is laughing prison
sentence if you knocked down any statues
two months ago and since then we haven't
seen much of them
we had to send border security
we sent actually homeland and border and
different forms of homeland to
to portland in order to you you know
what we had to do we had to save
they wanted to knock down a courthouse a
500 million dollar courthouse they
wanted to burn it down knock it down
and they were easily easy able to defend
but
the mayor and the governor of the state
they didn't want to do that
and we actually sent our our people
there and they did a great job and they
were they did it easily but
yeah in the meantime they went to other
parts of the city and they're doing
damage and
we're recommending to the governor that
the question was about a redirect of
some antifa website to biden's website
willing to get we would we would stop
that problem in one hour
the redirect we sent just defensive
measures to protect and save that
courthouse from being burned down or
knocked down
we also saved a couple of other
buildings federal buildings
sure because they were unable to do the
job sure i have to say this they have
really good police they have a great
group of people
that if they would be allowed to do
their job same with chicago and same
with new york and a couple of other
cities
if they allowed you in chicago 25 000
police
and they're really good but they're not
allowed to do their job
in new york you have new york's finest
but they've totally taken away
their incentive they've they've taken
away their lives in a sense because they
don't allow them to do their job they
could do that job so easily you wouldn't
have a problem in new york
and that includes with terrorism and
everything else disbanded
they've cut by uh one billion dollars
their budget in new york one billion
dollars and crime is up by
200 250 depends on what week you're
looking at it's crazy what's going on in
new york
we could solve that problem easily but
we don't have to remember the question
was about a redirect of a some antifa
website to biden's website supposedly
and now he's on to this it's an honor
they have to give the honor back to
their law enforcement groups
new york is great so is chicago
and in portland they could do the job if
they don't want to do that
we would send in gladly if they want the
national guard will take care of it in
one hour
right it'll go very quickly as we did by
the way if you take a look in
minneapolis when they were burning down
minneapolis a wonderful place but
nobody's ever seen anything like it
after days
the very liberal and these are all run
by liberal democrats
every place i talk about is run because
we have great cities
and they're run by republicans
okay it's you know it's there's no magic
to it it's
obvious what's going on and these
the cities that i mentioned are all run
by liberal very liberal
democrats and it's very sad when you see
what's happening to new york it's very
sad when you see what's
happening to other cities not just those
three
other cities when you look at what's
happening it's not even
it's not even believable i left new york
almost four years ago
and you could see signs of problems
because de blasio was there he's a
horrific mayor just horrific
i mean people don't want to go there
anymore right
he's not only is it bad with crime in
the way he talks about the city and what
he does he's
horrific i i do agree this is the worst
one i've never seen one this bad
and i know he hasn't said plasma but but
this is crazy
this is crazy when i look and see what's
happening to
a city that i love that still has great
potential
but it's going to have to be brought
back
because new york has potential it's an
up and coming city someday it may be a
real city
not even believable what's happening in
chicago where
one weekend you have 78 people shot and
18
die in a weekend
and then successive weekends you have so
much of that happening and
it's it's not even it's really not even
believable
and if you fatality less democrats run
this country and we've stopped it from
going
other places if you let democrats run
this country
you'll have all of your cities be just
like this
thank you mr president the heads of the
boston and
dallas fed today said that the economy
hasn't recovered strong enough because
the country hasn't contained the virus
right so what's your response to them
and what did that argue for a stronger
federal response